I don't get it it's just not fun I'm so
done with this you mark walberg the
other day when I was on Instagram I saw
that Mark Wahlberg posted his daily
schedule and it is absolutely ridiculous
hi wakes up at 2:30 in the morning every
single day no matter what
and then he works out twice he goes
golfing he freezes his body and I think
it's just ridiculous and you know what
I'm kind of ridiculous - so for the next
24 hours I'm gonna look like Mark
Wahlberg I'm gonna do everything on his
daily schedule and I'm gonna try to
survive it because I I don't know this
is a lot and I like my sleep so I have
no idea how this is gonna go but for 24
hours you can call me Marky Mark - 32 in
the morning now and I'm getting up to
start my day because Mark Wahlberg gets
up at 2:30 so
yay
I feel pretty tired I fell asleep
probably around 11
and this is so stupid well how did I do
this it's 2:45 right now and at 2:45
Mark Wahlberg prays I've never prayed
before in my life
I'm not sure how people do this so for
me today I'm just gonna watch a video
about Oprah because I guess that she's
the closest thing to God and that I can
think of I turned the light off while
I'm watching Oprah oh no I'm just cold
and tired why does he do this hmm I
don't get it
[Music]
it's 3:15 that means it's time to have
my first meal of the day and get ready
for the gym so that's what Mark Wahlberg
does
by 3:15 in the morning
[Music]
so I am heading downstairs to go to the
gym my first workout of the day Mark
Wahlberg does too every day did my
prayer time and breakfast awake I'm
ready to do this there's no one else in
the whole gym and why would there be
it's 3:40 in the morning I realized I
forgot my headphones but it doesn't
matter no I'm serious so I'm just gonna
have my music on loud anyway but it's
too early you can see it's still dark
outside this is ridiculous Hugh Mark
Wahlberg is a 6:00 a.m. it means it's
time for my shower Mark Wahlberg takes
90 minutes hours he's showers from 6:00
to 7:30 and I don't make millions of
dollars a year so I'm not gonna take a
90-minute shower because I have to pay
for my water I'm gonna take a shower
then I'll get ready and then I get to go
golfing is
6:45 right now I am on my way to the
Chelsea Piers to go to the driving range
because Mark Wahlberg plays golf every
day at 7:30 and Suns coming up getting
lighter outside which is nice it's
really interesting to be on the subway
and see all the morning commuters
because there they're all just starting
their day right now and my days already
been going on for over four hours which
is wild I'm really tired and hungry
surprisingly even though I just ate but
I don't think my body knows what time it
is I'm at Chelsea Piers I'm about to go
hit some golf balls and I haven't done
this for years and years probably been
like 10 years since I hit up a golf ball
so I'm very nervous but should be fun so
I just got done with the driving range
wow I'm really bad at that but it was
actually really fun I know for a fact my
swing was not good I already feel it in
my shoulders the neck but I guess it's
good that my next thing is the
cryotherapy session so I've been up for
like six hours already this is insane
I've done so much already whatever now I
have to go uptown to the crowd chamber I
just finished my cryotherapy session
that was probably one of the coolest
things I've done I still have goose
bumps on my arms even though I finished
a couple minutes ago it got very very
cold obviously and I was shivering the
whole time
but it was worth it I'm glad I lasted as
long as I did but um yeah that was all
so it is after ten get to eat in a
couple minutes that'll be really good my
body needs that I don't know how he only
has a couple snacks so far I think the
second half of the day is gonna be a lot
easier but um yeah of a couple more
hours left and cue mark walberg this is
so stupid
why do you do this every single day is
11 o'clock in the morning up next is
work and meetings and family time I
don't live in the same state as any of
the members of my immediate family so I
tried to FaceTime two of my brothers and
they both ignored my calls so I guess
I'll just get back to work it is 1:00
o'clock which means luckily it's time
for lunch I am so hungry
I literally ran to the fridge to get my
food I don't know how he spaces out his
meals like it just doesn't make any
sense to me the the space that was so
much time how is he not starving
I was just sitting with other people at
work as they lunch and it made me so
hungry but I knew I couldn't eat just
yet I'm exhausted I need this food
luckily it'll give me some energy but I
don't think it's gonna last too long
and it is 2 p.m. I'm exhausted I've been
up for almost 12 hours now but it's fine
I'm almost through the day at 2 p.m. he
does work calls and meetings and I
didn't have any so I tried calling one
of my other brothers for FaceTime and he
ignored me too so I'll call them back
later it's just not fun I don't know I
feel like I'm just saying the same
things over and over now a little
delusional yeah 3:15 and Mark Wahlberg
always picks up his kids at 3:15 from
school and I don't have any kids and I
thought that would be kind of weird if I
picked random kids up at school so I
picked up something that was very near
and dear to my heart it's been free
shopping I believe that's an equal
trade-off that's like a fair switch so
we've got my food have dinner tonight
and I'm so tired but I have to get ready
for the gym very shortly
just finished what felt like my 12th
snack of the day
have more yogurt I'm on my way to the
gym but the second time today I'm
already pretty exhausted so I don't know
how I'm gonna do going to the gym again
I feel like I don't have anything
interesting to say and I just keep
repeating the same things over and over
I looked on Mark Wahlberg's histogram he
posts a lot of workouts where he doesn't
elevate a push-up so I made sure I did a
lot of those today
five o'clock for speed I'm done work out
two of the day
and think I might take a nap us for
right now I never want to do this again
after your shower all right guys the
finished second workout of the day got
my shower I'm tired I am hitting home
right now
we're gonna make some food
to go to sleep because I only need to be
awake for two more hours and I cannot
wait all right
it is after 5:30 and that means it is
time to cook dinner because that's what
Mark Wahlberg does so I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna eat and I'm gonna pass out
all right so it's 6:30 at night I've
been up for 16 hours already gonna close
the curtains and hopefully I'll be able
to sleep soon Mark Wahlberg goes to bed
at 7:30 so we have one more hour he has
family time right now so I called my mom
and talked to her and hopefully I'll be
able to sleep soon we'll see I'm almost
done I don't know how he does this I
don't know why he does this
I just woke up it is 719 which is great
because I fell asleep probably around
8:30 last night
I don't know how Mark Wahlberg does it
my neck is actually kind of sword from
from golf gloves they had no idea what I
was doing
okay I don't recommend anyone does this
ever how he does it this is not fun what
else is it but Mark Wahlberg looks good
so if he wants to go to the gym twice he
wants to do all these things because
working for him for them good for him
but
is not for me
[Music]
you